white house will have questions
for days on this.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate that.
Let's discuss now a CNN
national security analyst and
former director of national
intelligence, James clapper.
Director, thank you for being
with us.
We appreciate it.
Just your reaction to the
decision to wait to shoot this
balloon down after a reach the
atlantic as opposed to earlier
in the week.
What is your sense of how this
went down?
>> I think it was the right
thing to do, I think there is a
balance drawn here by affirming
our sovereignty and at the same
time, protecting its safety of
people below.
I can imagine the reaction if
the thing had blown up and been
shot down over a red state and
somebody got killed or heard or
there was property damage and
the outrage that would result
from not.
This was the best of both
worlds for me.
As I understand, it it was
within our territorial waters
and obviously, no jeopardy to
anyone on the ground.
So, to me it was the right
thing to do I think.
This will afford us some
diplomatic leverage with the
Chinese.
>> That leads me to my next
question, what do you think the
Chinese were up to?
Obviously, they had to assume
we were going to see this thing
in the sky.
And this was going to be
detected.
Does that tell us a little bit
about what their motivations
might have been?
>> No.
To me, this is a mystery.
The why exactly they did this
--
that is why I have a tendency
to accept the explanation that
this was something that went
astray.
I don't buy what they are
saying was --
that is why this will be very
good to recover the payload
from the balloon and understand
what kinds of sensors it had on.
As others have discussed, the
Chinese have very good overhead
satellite systems that can
collect all kinds of imagery
intelligence.
Probably better than with a
balloon.
The issue for me is what other
kinds of sensors or phenomenon
olive tree that this balloon
was trying to collect and
hopefully we will learn that by
exploiting the payload.
>> The balloon might not have
been just taking pictures, is
that right?
>> Exactly, if it was just
taking pictures, and I really
don't understand that.
Because as I say, the Chinese
overhead satellites can do
every bit what that balloon
could do and more.
Now, if it was somehow
intercepting radiation,
non-literal communications,
literal communications, I don't
know.
We will learn that.
But it just seems to me strange
that the Chinese would
intentionally do this,
particularly at this particular
time.
>> The balloon we are told will
be analyzed once it is
retrieved at an FBI lab in
quantico.
How critical is it at this
point for Navy divers, assets
there in atlantic right now,
retrieving this, how critical
is it for them to get that
piece of equipment out of the
water?
>> Pretty critical, because it
was designed to survive in a
wet environment and that is not
the environment it was
operating in.
So, the quicker the divers can
get to it and retreat, it be
better.
Again, I don't know the depth
of the water where it actually
fell.
That will be another challenge,
depending on how deep the water
is, about the quicker the
better.
>> You were director of
national intelligence, maybe
you can answer this question?
Is this unusual?
Do you have spy balloons flying
over the continental united
States?
>> Yes, I don't recall an
instance of it during my time
as being --
for six and a half years.
I don't recollect this.
I will tell you, I've had some
personal experience with using
balloons as intelligence
collectors, particularly for
imagery, and they're not very
efficient for that purpose.
That is why I am a little bit
skeptical of imagery.
And they are so subject to the
vagaries of weather.
Missed, fog, rain.
And especially as we've seen in
this case, wind.
They are hard to control.
I am very interested to learn,
if we can, publicly, just what
sort of sensor sweep was in the
payload of the balloon.
>> And do we have the technical
capabilities do you think to
already know what this balloon
was doing, what the
surveillance equipment was
doing.
Could they have gotten an up
close look of it before it was
shot down to know exactly what
this thing is?
>> I will just say that that is
possible, I don't know, either
through direct observation or
indirect collection from some
other source.
So, it's possible, but I'm just
speculating here.
>> Yeah.
One of the interesting things
that Oren Liebermann was
reporting earlier this
afternoon is that the U.S. Says
it was able to prevent the
balloon from gaining
intelligence.
That they could do some
mitigation efforts.
It sounded as though they were
talking about jamming the
balloon to some extent.
What do you think about that?
>> One thing I wondered about
is if it had some sort of
communication relaces.
Either through satellites or
some other terrestrial --
that we somehow got access to.
I don't know.
If that were the case, well
certainly, they could jam that
and prevent the transmission.
Either guidance to the balloon,
if it had that, or from sensor
or sensors on the balloon and
interfere with that --
it is quite conceivable.
>> One of the questions I think
that is floating around that is
highly intriguing as what does
this say about Chinese
espionage efforts in the united
States?
It looks like they were doing
some over the United States.
But what does it say about
Chinese espionage efforts
inside the United States and
how extensive they are?
Because I imagine the American
people might surmise that it's
going on and it's expensive.
But how extensive?
>> It's a great question.
Because what is so significant
and dramatic about this is it
is very visible.
The Chinese have reconnaissance
satellites that signal
intelligence collectors and
imagery intelligence collectors
that are traversing over united
States every day, collecting
reams of intelligence.
They have very aggressive
intellectual property attacks
on us.
So, they are very aggressive
about the us.
Having settled at, this to me
is sort of ham-handed to do
this as an intelligence
collection effort when they
have so many other ways of
gaining intelligence on the
United States that is not
nearly as visible and dramatic
as this and this is what is
drawn so much attention to
this.
We're concerned about our
sovereignty.
How high does sovereignty go?
So, we will shoot down the
balloon because it's an affront
to our sovereignty.
Well, the satellite I guess you
could argue are an affront to
our sovereignty as well and
were not about shoot them down.
>> That's right.